was wird bloß aus annegret kramp
karrenbauer ihre beliebtheitswerte ihr
kleinen heuchlerisch ihre
beliebtheitswerte sind seit monaten im
freien fall
und jetzt haben wir noch die frechen
kleinen branchen von der jungen union
mehrheitlich dafür plädiert den nächsten
kanzlerkandidaten per urwahl zu
bestimmen
das ist eine totale demütigung für ak ja
damit damit läuft quasi ihre rückstände
antrag nach püttlingen wird denn
eigentlich traditionell hat die
vorsitzenden den erstzugriff auf den
begehrten spitzenkandidaten job gut ob
der große cdu-parteitag im november
damit macht das ist noch offen aber es
war schon brutal schon hart wie die
junge union auf ihrem deutschlandtag
sämtliche aka rivalen ab gefeiert hat
alter wer braucht mit jura märz sowie
salam tussi ich kann bald wiederholen
ein panorama romans der leicht
verschwitzte sexgott rechts im bild
ist übrigens tilman kube vorsitzender
der jungen union seien deutschlandtag
stand offenbar unter dem motto des alten
märchens hänsel die gretel
ich meine wie will die cdu denn mit
einer frau ins kanzlerin gehen die in
der eigenen partei so demontiert wird
öffentlich was der herr kuban über kaka
sagt das ist jedenfalls ja keine
liebeserklärung im engeren sinne
die parteivorsitzende ist immer eine von
den kandidatinnen die sicherlich auch
die möglichkeit haben muss in erwägung
gezogen zu werden
ohne scheiß mit dem slogan sollte
annegret unbedingt in den nächsten
wahlkampf ziehen
die parteivorsitzende ist immer eine von
den kandidatinnen die sicherlich auch
die möglichkeit haben uns in erwägung
gezogen zu werden
hkk die arme annegret muss ich jetzt
echt ein paar ganz neue fragen stellen
was wird dann aus meinem arbeitsplatz
wie geht's für mich walter kann ich
meine familie noch ernähren
ich meine
ich höre immer nur ich ich ich aber
wirklich und ohne witz einer frau wie
die junge union ak cars konkurrenten da
jubelt hat als gäb's kein morgen vor
allem der auftritt von friedrich merz
das war fast schon so etwas wie youporn
wirklich jetzt wirklich wobei ich sagen
muss es ist gar nicht so schwer diese
junge union zum jubeln zu bringen
eigentlich musste nur sagen scheiß auf
klima wir machen politik für normale
deutsche ihr keinen bock mehr haben sich
einzuschränken und ja es ist einfach
leute geben die im sommer in den
sommerurlaub nach mal fliegen liebe
freundinnen und freunde und dafür
ok
und dass er da auch so abgeht meine güte
forscher haben jetzt herausgefunden
während man dieses lied singt sterben
gehirnzellen ähnlich abgegangen ist der
saal übrigens als tilman kuban gesagt
hat er sei gegen freibier für
flüchtlinge
klar weil die junge union auf keinen
tropfen bier verzichten will
was für party people bestellen sie jetzt
dj kuban und die malibu mit den geilsten
junge union party jetzt lass die sau
raus bei
ein ganzer märz auf dem flur la la la
halt abfeiern mit dem singenden hobbit
aus düsseldorf komm hol den
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist schwarz
cham
im grunde wollen sie jeden als kanzler
nur sie nicht
kein hahn mehr nach der anderen
kein mensch mit andere kriegen
jetzt noch einfacher
[Musik]
dj kuba und die malediven nicht einmal
besoffen zu ertragen
[Applaus]
man auch ohne alkohol könig sein
aber nicht bei der jungen union feiert
immer weiter ich aber prophezeie euch am
sechsten dezember ist die party vorbei
ja dann ist spd parteitag dann gehen die
sozen raus aus der gruppe und wird doch
wohl noch träumen dürfen
wobei wobei die bertelsmann stiftung hat
jetzt groko halbzeitbilanz gezogen und
was überraschendes festgestellt die spd
war in dieser groko tierisch fleißig die
union war ja hier am chillen würde man
heute tragen mehr als 60 prozent der
groko wahlversprechen wurden wohl schon
umgesetzt oder in angriff genommen aber
das ist ganz ausdrücklich kein verdienst
von cdu csu
die spd konnte von 73 wahlversprechen 33
umsetzen
cdu und csu von 32 14
diese fleißigen kleinen männchen und
keiner merkts laut umfragen das ist
schade und eigentlich auch ungerecht mit
der neuen parteispitze kommt
wahrscheinlich demnächst die wende
seit dem letzten wochenende wissen sie
ist die spd ja endlich durch mit ihren
ganzen regionalkonferenzen bei denen
sich sechs mögliche führungsduos
herausgeschält haben aus denen die
parteibasis jetzt wählen darf und damit
nicht genug alle paare absolvieren wird
außerdem noch ein castingformat bei sat
1 für uns hinter den kulissen dabei
christian ehring
[Musik]
dass die zeiten schwierig sind das
wissen wir nicht nur in deutschland
wer sich in europa und wir sind hier
live bei sat 1 das ist dieser niveaulose
privaten dadurch voll gemein war zu
unserer kiwis im fernsehgarten
wir erleben gerade den auftritt von olaf
scholz r redet jetzt seit etwas mehr als
zwei stunden und noch hat sich niemand
aus der jury umgedreht aber es müsste
eigentlich es mich eigentlich müsste es
müsste wirklich jetzt eigentlich jeden
moment passieren oder auch nicht seltsam
eigentlich den scholz und klara geywitz
sind ja top favoriten weil sie es weil
sie es drauf haben urlaub zum beispiel
kann alle sachen super gut erklären ich
kann ein ziemlich viele sachen ziemlich
gut auf den punkt bringen
außerdem kann sie wohl schleife und
freihändig fahrrad fahren jetzt könnte
man einwenden weniger neu anfangen als
mit olaf scholz geht ja gar nicht denn
er hat den schwarzen gürtel in schwarze
null
er war agenda bahn und er hat die rente
mit 67 durchgeboxt alles richtig aber
ich habe dafür gesorgt dass es in diesem
land ein kurzarbeitergeld gab ich bin
der meinung dass sich ein echter truly
sozialdemokraten und das wird ihnen bei
der bundestagswahl leider juli gar nicht
helfen
sie konnte will sich sido umdrehen aber
klar bei diesem casting treten auch noch
ganz andere kaliber an gesine schwan zum
beispiel tolle frau problem egal wie
klug sie redet alle gucken immer nur auf
ralf stegner und ich bin generell dafür
nicht die deponien in der partei mehr
das sagen zu geben sondern überhaupt den
kommunen sehr viel mehr finanziellen
spielraum zu geben
da hast du keine chance gegen liveticker
hast du keine chance bis 10.000 volt
quasi so etwas wie das gesicht zu den
aktuellen umfrage werden und ja dann gab
es ja vorhin leider noch ein ganz ganz
schlimmen fremdschäm momente und willy
brandt der würde wahrscheinlich heute
hier stehen und sagen liebe genossinnen
liebe genossen wir wollen gute nachbarn
sein nach innen und nach außen
ja und das war der moment als boris
pistorius chancen endgültig aus spaß die
parteibasis ist übrigens super happy
mit ihrem casting allerdings sind die
umfragen weiter katastrophal
frage könnte es also sein dass ist die
bevölkerung doch irgendwie üben wenn
eine partei sie monatelang nur mit sich
selbst beschäftigt nur eine theorie ich
glaube riga wie möchte sich umdrehen ja
doch ich weiß was ich gehe jetzt auch
noch ausrichten er hat ja nicht so dass
wir fortschritte sat 1 wie unsere und
dass wir noch nach über einer stunde
[Applaus]
[Musik]